oh
from British Columbia in the west to
Nova Scotia in the East Canadian
firefighters are on the front lines of a
nationwide Wildfire emergency
3.3 million hectares of burn so far this
year across the country there are
currently 413 wildfires burning in 249
of those fires are deemed out of control
and as of yesterday an estimated 26
thousand people remain evacuated from
their homes across the country
wet weather in Nova Scotia one of the
hardest hit areas helped firefighters
gain control over some blazes there's
been 90 millimeters of rain over the
last few days which is definitely
helping us out greatly down here
unusually high temperatures and tender
dry forests are what making this fire
season so devastating global warming is
at the root of the crisis says Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau who warns
that even worse may be on the way year
after year with climate change we're
seeing more and more intense wildfires
and in places where they don't normally
happen our modeling shows that this may
be an especially severe Wildfire season
throughout the summer
we're going to get through this together
and our government will keep being there
with whatever it takes to keep people
safe in Quebec where 160 fires are
burning authorities said the danger of
lung damage from heavy smoke is so bad
that residents in some areas were urged
to wear respirators if they ventured
outside Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera